let's do a live you wrote it cuz you
wrote this book here in front of us but
we are doing it live the conversation I
am your host Alicia Krause and with me
is the one and only Ben Shapiro who will
be taking your questions live for an
entire hour so usually at this point I
lecture you guys about how you should
become daily wire subscribers and only
subscribers get to ask the questions
well this time we want to kick things
off by announcing that this is a very
special episode of the conversation
because we're actually doing a live
signing of Ben's new book the right side
of history and so for this episode you
don't have to be a subscriber to ask a
question because when you purchase a
copy of Ben's book you can write in a
question for him to answer live on the
air as he's over here signing your book
and getting what like crammed hands
we're gonna give you our threat today we
got so many questions and so many books
to sign so head on over to premier
collectibles dot-com / ben shapiro
and get your signed copy now and don't
worry because if your question isn't
answered you will still get a signed
copy of the book that's premier eclipse
- collectibles calm / ben shapiro and
can't wait to get started you have so
many over here let's just you're like
let's go you gotta flap it and open it
up to the right page exactly where do
you like this sign so now they've got
the sticker here so normally uh-huh I
sign on this here page so you're not
supposed to sign on that here page and
that's what they did the Reagan Library
yesterday how did that event go it went
great it was it was a blast and I mean
first of all you're speaking at the
Reagan Library which is super awesome
yeah so this question is from Kelly so
this book is gonna be for Kelly which is
super fun and she asked she so she asked
about when abortion is outlawed and even
prior to this happening what are your
solutions to help women and their babies
who are faced with an unplanned or
unwanted pregnancy specifically unwed
and young mother I mean this is where
the social fabric comes in when I talk
about as you talked about a lot in this
book the fact that you can't have a free
society where we're not compelling
people to help each other unless people
are voluntarily helping each other in in
our community in our Jewish community
when people have problems then the first
place you go is your family and then
more largely to your religious community
and
after that maybe you go to local
government than state government and
federal the problem is we've reversed
that process so one of the rips on folks
on the right when they say they're
pro-life is well you don't care about
the kids after they're born absolutely
false which is why people on the right
tend to give per capita a lot more
charity than people on the Left I mean
in my family would personally help out a
lot of folks in our community who are
who are in need in fact today is is a
fast day but tonight is is poram and on
that holiday one of the commandments is
methanol avium which is to give gifts to
the poor so I mean this is something
that Village People of course have long
been famous for all right do you give
the gift basket yeah that's another one
and you guys dress up yep yep this year
what my kids are going as the Dragons we
how train your dragon dragon wait oh the
the one that's invisible my son is the
black one my daughter is the white one
yeah I haven't seen a new one yet but
this one was so cute nor have I but it's
out the theaters though you should go
take all right this next question and
his next book are for Zachary he says hi
Ben I'm a middle school math teacher in
an extremely impoverished and rural
region the average income in my County
is less than $17,000 per capita I've
noticed a complete lack of values in my
area and many did not graduate high
school due to simply being passed on by
the school system without ever having to
do work in school to give you an idea my
8th grade math classroom had less than
20% of proficiency
coming into the year with many on a 4th
to 5th grade math level I have students
who refuse to do a lick of work because
at the end of the day it is my tail on
the line being held fully responsible
for their failure even when no effort is
put forth what can you tell me about an
area would you come out into this yeah
and what do you think it would take to
turn this situation around I mean the
truth is that when it comes to the
educational system generally there's a
lot of pressure put on teachers but the
vast majority of education and
educational values start with parents
and that's why you're seeing in New York
City right now a lot of pressure on the
elite high schools Stuyvesant High
School because they're not admitting
enough black and Hispanic students and
the complaint is that somehow this is
racist well the vast majority of
students who go to that school who are
impoverished are Asian students there is
a difference in cultures of poverty and
non cultures
that's not racially broken-down there
are black cultures in which in the
United States in which education is
highly valued their black cultures in
which it is not their white cultures in
which it is highly valued their white
cultures in which it is not it all
starts at home obviously with parents
and then the teacher just has to do what
the teacher can do but if you're not in
charge of that all you can do is is do
your best for the students the only way
to inculcate the value of education is
to recognize from an early age that it's
the parents job to make sure that their
kids are educated which is why when my
ancestors got here when my great-great
grandparents got to the United States
about 1907 then no English didn't have
any money the first thing they made sure
is that their kids spoke English and
that their kids were interested in being
well educated this has been true in the
Jewish community for a very long time
for example all right Joshua has the
next question what do you believe it's
the best way we can fight to protect the
life of the unborn politician after
politician says they will get right
against it and then they get in and do
absolutely nothing have we already lost
the battle we haven't lost the cultural
battle that's what you're seeing a year
on your decrease in the number of
abortions in the United States and the
abortion rate has been going down
consistently for years you're also
seeing the rate of people who are
pro-life rising continuously because
there are so many people who are seeing
ultrasound pictures and understanding
that these are in fact actual children
in the womb as far as legislation I
think that you are seeing gradual
pushing back of the of the dates at
which you can perform an abortion in
some states if one so far as to actually
do heartbeat bills where they say once
the baby's heart is beating which is 22
days that at that point you can't have
an abortion so you are seeing those
those restrictions being broadened the
question is how far the Supreme Court is
going to allow those restrictions to be
broadened I think it's probably going to
be a gradual process on the federal
level the fact that the Republicans in
Congress did not shut down the
government to defund Planned Parenthood
but did shut down the government for the
border wall I think tells you something
about their priorities and I think that
thing I'm for the border wall I still
think that prioritization is incorrect
it's really sad when you see that hell
yeah Allison wants to know what is one
agenda item you would most push for if
you were president also what year are
you running again what did the dirty
shirts say oh that's 20 the t-shirt says
20 24 the real answer is never but come
on I want to be your say
Huckabee Sanders really yeah that's it
that's well not totally yeah I mean come
on by I mean I could be the Sarah
Huckabee so I know everyone in the in of
it is in a 500-foot radius of where I
said loses their job if I do that so I
think that I'm gonna go on that no they
wouldn't
they wouldn't we're planning this too
far in advance okay you raise more than
bait though I can't remember the
question what was the question so what
would your top priority be if you're
president my top priority would be
cutting the size of the executive branch
so I think the president has two jobs
one is to employment policy the others
to educate the public I like to educate
the public every day on my shows I mean
that's that's what I'm interested in
doing that I'm doing with the book and
then on the other side what you're
trying to do is implement policy my view
is that the executive branch is far too
large the one thing I can do without
congressional approval is simply slice
the executive branch to ribbons that's
what I would do I would fire nearly
everyone in the executive branch and I
would I would get it back to enforcing
the laws that are on the books and
pretty much that's it looking to
eliminate full departments including the
Department of Education that there's
there two million people who work for
the executive branch of the government
that's insane
it's insane Zachary wants to know are
there any Republicans you could feel
could currently primary against Trump in
2020 and be successful the answer's no
and that's because President Trump has
72 in depending on the poll seventy to
ninety percent approval rating inside
the Republican Party I also think that
it would be counterproductive because I
think the media would then try and
suggest that there is dichotomy in the
Republican Party between the true
conservatives who vote for John Kasich
or something and the people who vote for
Trump and that of course is not the real
story a lot of people will vote for
Trump they feel he has the best chance
to win a lot of them will vote from
because they don't like John Kasich
that's not a divide between
conservatives and non conservatives and
then anybody who votes against Trump
will be seen as some sort of a traitor a
heretic who has to be cast out it
creates divisions in the service of
pretty much nothing cuz Trump's gonna
win the nomination anyway all right
Brittany wants to know by the way I love
all these questions from females like we
don't notice that but I didn't see I
don't see I don't see gender no that's
not much you identify as a pregnant
blood lady today
would you like to swap not at all it's
real uncomfortable
but it's wonderful Brittany wants to
know what do you think would be the
first thing we should change to make
America the land of opportunity again
well I think the first thing that we
have to change honestly is our own
mentality about America because America
is a land of opportunity and right now I
think there are politicians on both
sides of the aisles and political
figures on both sides of the aisle who
are maintaining that you're a victim of
circumstance if you live in the United
States you see this from the populace
right well we should shut down automatic
driving we should we should worry about
trade we should worry about Mexican land
and China instead of saying listen there
are 7 million unfilled jobs go out there
and adventure right you're not
guaranteed anything in this life and
certainly in the United States except
for that adventure so make the decisions
that are most likely to bring you
success if you actually want to have
opportunity you have to seize
opportunity and opportunity is knocking
every day that you live in the freest
country that's ever been created
all right Alisha has an interesting
question she wants to know if you ever
had to leave America would you consider
moving to Japan - Japan
I've never even visited Japan so I
hesitate to say I would move to a place
I've never visited I want to visit Japan
though apparently it's pretty amazing
I've heard there's some good food
there's some beautiful scenery I down
lots of kosher restaurants so yeah but
also it's really cold there yeah people
don't realize that but it's quite cold
there because I've had some friends that
are based in the military that over
there Dina wants to know you have
mentioned having more children before
how many kids are you planning to have
and can you speak about large families
versus small families thank you for your
honest commentary for for your
information I'm a married father of four
and an NYPD lieutenant with 26 years on
the job first of all thanks for what you
do because you're out there in the line
of duty doing stuff to protect us every
day we are aiming for I hope you know
God willing at least for kids that's
what we would like to do maybe wind up
with fewer maybe we end up with more but
for my wife has for and her family I
formed my family for seems like a nice
number yeah the the social studies tend
to show interestingly enough that
parents are happiest that the couples
are happiest when they either have no
kids or lots of kids when you have one
or two kids you put so much stake in the
one or two kids that you invest all your
time and energy in those in the perfect
life and then as you have more kids you
notice this between kid 1 and kid too I
mean you have a couple of kids now you
notice this with kid one you're like I'm
gonna be so meticulous about every
little thing and bye kid - you're like
finding it off the floor I don't even
care anymore just do what you need to do
because this is the
the real-world man learn to survive and
by the time you hit kid for kid born is
taken care a kid for so it really does
create a sense of camaraderie and
there's a constant fun going on I loved
having three younger siblings and and I
think that as a parent having more kids
as opposed to fewer kids I think it's a
pretty wonderful thing I mean the
religious Jewish community of course is
famous for having lots of kids it's so
funny when my parents would go out in
public in the secular community
everybody would look at them like what
the hell did you do there are four of
them and then they go in the religious
community and somebody be like knew what
happened where the rest um I was at
Ralph's the other day and some man who
does not deserve to be called a
gentleman it's like oh my god why would
you have three cuz there are three girls
in tow and I was like for like who does
that well you should have said to him
you know what I'm having the kids so you
don't have to yeah I just just you don't
know I plan for conservatism to take
over is we're just gonna be fit Emma
graphic argument for conservatism
remains pretty strong I mean I'm just
saying Elijah wants to know hey Ben how
do you justify religiously based
political views to adamantly
non-religious people so I don't justify
religiously based political views I
justify reasonably based political views
I believe that every public policy has
to have a secular rationale otherwise we
can't have a common conversation now
with that said religious values can back
that rationale so what I mean by that is
to take an example this entire book is
about how secular values that we all
hold dear things like freedom of speech
and free markets are actually rooted in
judeo-christian values about the fact
that we are all made in God's image that
we are individuals with creative
capacity that the universe is an
understandable place where we ought to
be able to use reason these are
religious assumptions these are not
assumptions you can make if you are a
scientific materialist those are
religiously based but making those
assumptions now you have to make a
secular argument for why public policy
ought to prevail along some lines or
other lines but the assumptions that you
make from the outset are very rarely
based in simple evidence assumptions
that you make politically or values wise
are generally based in a religious
underpinning which is why when I debated
Sam Harrison I asked him you know why do
you think our values are so similar even
though you're a militant atheist not an
Orthodox Jew the answer is because we
grew up in a judeo-christian society
with 3,000 years of common
three ten miles from each other do you
think that he's read this book not yet I
hope he does I mean I do mention him in
it really I'd love to yeah I talk about
him Michael Shermer has interviewed me
about the book I mention Michael in here
I mean these are all people I think who
are trying to do something good which is
restore enlightenment values but they're
doing this on the base of a basis of a
secular materialism that I think is
insufficient to support the the
superstructure of enlightenment values
enlightenment was not purely secular it
was based on a long history of religious
values there was an interesting
conversation I saw in a Twitter thread
earlier yes interesting things do still
happen on Twitter guys but stay away and
someone said he wondered how many people
would convert to Judaism after reading
this and then somebody else is like oh
actually wrote a thought piece about how
I actually think people would convert to
Christianity needs a review of the books
actually a really good review the book
by Catholic person who is reading it and
saying you know you really need is more
Jesus in the book
yes more Jesus also we get to eat bacon
so there's that I mean I'm starving
today
I'm sorry eating anything would be good
I feel like I don't even want to take a
sip of my water in front of you right
now I feel really bad it's you're loud
by the way pregnant women don't have to
fast and even in Judaism if they fit in
dangerously and I ain't Jewish so yeah
so you don't it's a double whammy you
don't have to worry about under any
that's if I converted you right now you
still would not have to worry great
services what books would you recommend
for a young man who's 12 years old and
is interested in being a wise leader
well there you know if you're if you're
interested in sort of leadership
qualities and being a valuable human
being there's this this series that my
dad grew up on and then passed on to me
it's an older series they've done a
rewrite of the of the series to make it
more Christian and orientation but it
was originally a non-religious series at
all it's called the chip Hilton series
it's a series of sports books if you're
a 12-year old boy it's just fantastic
stuff and dates back to the 1950s and it
is you know replete with just good
values it is racially diverse and all of
that it's it's it's really these books
are really fantastic they're very hard
to find that the full series of the chip
Hilton books is worth thousands of
dollars but they've brought out reissues
that have some Christian themes in them
and they made people more openly
religious and so those I'm sure those
are quite good as well I obviously
prefer the older versions because
they're the original I would also have
to add I don't know how much they've
changed but the original boy scout code
of conduct well yeah I mean like a great
place to start
young man yeah well the only problems
that the state of California threatened
to revoke their 501 C 3 exemption if
they actually held to its of course that
Toby wants to know do you believe that
Cuban people will ever rise up against
their government similar to the
Venezuelan people well it depends I mean
I think that the Army is being paid off
by the in the same way as in Venezuela
the Army's being paid off by the
administration in Cuba it's one of the
reasons why I'm not largely in favor of
the quote-unquote opening of Cuba absent
other measures of pressure that we can
bring to bear I think that tends to
reinsure I the people who are in power
it doesn't really tend to help the
people who are at the bottom of the
ladder who are gonna have their wealth
seized and then the people in power just
take the money and then redistribute it
to all their friends honestly I don't
know the answer to that I'm not I'm not
knowledgeable enough about the internal
politics of Cuba right now I mean
obviously you hold but you hope that the
people at around rise up you hope that
the people in in Cuba rise up you you
hope that Venezuela's Revolution is
successful as well all right Cherie
wants to know why do you think some
people are so easily led to believe
non-scientific things like boys can
become girls and girls can become boys
or that a 40 week old fetus is not an
actual baby I think because we have
chosen to do away with I talk about
exactly the stuff in this book I think
that we have chosen to do away with the
notion of objective facts and and
scientific rationales it's because we're
finding more more meaning in our
feelings we're finding more meaning in
subjectivism objective reality is harsh
I mean that you don't get everything you
want
reality is what it is and sometimes that
doesn't meet your expectations of what
you think reality should be and in an
era where we have decided that we're
gonna find our happiness in self-esteem
we're gonna find our happiness and how
we feel today if reality doesn't meet
our self-esteem then we seek to change
the reality around us now we're going so
far as to change the actual biological
reality of sex and suggest that your
subjective perception of your own sex
somehow is more important to society at
large and to yourself than is your your
actual sexual biology that's a that's a
pretty radical statement that we've made
about the non value of science and it's
why again I think that they the attempt
to crack down on this stuff via the use
of government is the highest form of
tyranny I mean there's a case in the
last couple of days in which woman in
Britain is now being investigated by the
police for a quote-unquote misgendering
somebody so turn
somebody by their biological pronoun is
now considered a crime in parts of
Britain I mean that's that's an insane
contention and obviously a rejection
meant a rejection of both
judeo-christian values an Enlightenment
values which are based on the same
belief that there is an objective
reality and you can understand it there
was even that recent case in Canada
where the parents were told by the court
that they could not refer to their
daughter as her birth name on her
certificate mm-hmm or they could face
jail time it's madness and it's scary I
mean when is it coming to California and
the only thing that's preventing this
presumably is the first amendment but
we'll we'll find out Trina wants to know
if you could choose to be remembered for
a single thing what would you choose I
think it's House asked you a similar
question like at the end of your life
yeah when you're gone how do you want to
be remember you know they say so so
there's something that occurred to me
after George HW Bush passed away which
is that George HW Bush was he was a good
man but he was not a great man what I
mean by that is that great men are the
people who think of their in historic
conflict situations and now they step
forward to Winston Churchill's the
Ronald Reagan's and part of that is just
having fate thrust on you certain
responsibilities and then you rise to
the occasion being a good man is to a
certain extent being more anonymous it's
doing the little things every day that
make that make civilization work I mean
the stuff that makes civilization work
yes you need the guy who is there
standing in the breach when something
terrible happens but you also need
people who are who are out there
building that social fabric and that's
the stuff that goes naan celebrated so
we all listen we all want to be
remembered because we think that that
somehow gives us eternal life is in the
memory of other people and if I'm
talking about you know what I want my
intellectual legacy to be I think that
this book is a very good place to start
I think it really does encompass a lot
of my philosophy but if you're talking
about what is this stuff at the end of
my life that I'm gonna value the most
it's the same stuff that I think most
people are gonna value the most my
relationship with my wife my
relationship with my kids my
relationship with God and that's not the
stuff that will be remembered that's
just the stuff that mattered alrighty
this next question comes from Connor he
wants to know there are there aspera
sorry are there aspects of Eastern
philosophies and religions that have
helped out the West sure I mean I think
that if you take a look at some of the
ideas in Buddhism about how to deal with
reality
that the essential notion which is that
it is your choice how to react to the
reality around you I mean there are lots
of good concepts there obviously
cultural appropriation is a very good
thing it's one thing the West is
actually unique in pursuing is taking
the best of other cultures and then
trying to integrate them into our own
culture that's when people rip on
cultural appropriation I think to myself
what why why and if you're talking about
you know discoveries of the East
obviously mathematics being discovered
in India the the discovery of gunpowder
I mean there are all sorts of great
inventions that happen outside the West
the point of the book is that the vast
expansion the almost Big Bang of human
development in terms of wealth in terms
of freedom that did happen in the West
so why did it happen in the West and not
there all right
this question comes from John why I'm
sorry who are your favorite and least
favorite Supreme Court justices so
currently my favorite Supreme Court
justice is Clarence Thomas it has been I
mean just a lie even when Scalia was
alive
Thomas was my favorite Supreme Court
justice because Scalia has views of
stare decisis that I don't think are
correct he was always talking about
which precedents he would obey in which
he wouldn't and Thomas's basic take was
I'm not gonna be a precedent if it's
wrong which I think is correct so he is
my favorite Supreme Court justice and
he's a very underrated writer as well
least favorite Supreme Court justice
notorious RBG is quite terrible I mean
she really is her opinions have nothing
to do with the Constitution there are
obvious political polemics they're
really radical so she is really really
awful historically were Supreme Court
justices obviously you have to go
through Tony the Supreme Court justice
who wrote the Dred Scott decision and if
you're talking historically great
Supreme Court justices then you would
have to pick presumably maybe John
Marshall at the outside of the court
though I disagree with Marbury vs.
Madison and then you would have to
honestly I think Thomas is an alzheimer
I think it's that good that's awesome
so John wants to know what point should
government intervention be used for the
environment this conversation came up a
lot recently I think with the the green
New Deal yeah yeah I mean the answer is
when externalities prevail then you have
to have government intervenes so the
general rule of politics John Stuart
Mill says this and I generally agree
with this is that I get to wave my fist
around until I hate you in the face at
that point I violated your rights well
the same thing is true environmentally I
don't get to pump sludge onto your land
if I do that I'm violating your rights
well if I'm pumping
materials into the air that are doing
damage air pollution then the government
has to regulate that and they have to
regulate that so that the Commons
don't become overrun with garbage and
it's not just you pumping sludge onto my
property if there's a public park and we
all own it in common and you decide to
pollute that then you have taken
advantage and you've and you've created
externalities the problem I see with
with a lot of environmental policy these
days is that the environmental policy
should in fact be decided at the
legislative level not at the regulative
level and then beyond that the left is
attempting to regulate the environment
in a way that is not actually going to
be even be useful so the green New Deal
is counterproductive I've said before
I'm fully willing to accept and I do
accept the the mathematics of the IPCC
now orin orin Cass makes this this
argument I agree with them the the IPCC
argument that we are going to warm
perhaps 3 degrees Celsius by the end of
the century I'll assume that that's true
they know the math better than I do I'm
not I'm not a scientist so I'll take
their word for it I will also take their
word for it when they say that none of
the solutions that are currently on the
table come close to working and that
when aoc talks about the Green Deal if
we brought the United States as
emissions to zero today that would lower
the total amount the total amount of
global warming by the end of the century
by 0.173 degrees Celsius out of 3
degrees Celsius so in other words if we
completely destroy the American economy
that's what we achieve that does not
seem like a solution to me what do you
think about the kind of outrage that
bado and AOC and others are creating
about this 12 year deadline well I mean
this is this is being exaggerated
because they're they're assuming that if
we hit the end of that 12 years then we
just sort of fall off a cliff but the
fact is that if we blow past that 12
years human beings have an innate
capacity to adapt how do they think that
human beings got to the United States
how do you think people got to America
okay this entire continent ire
continental shelf was not populated
originally by human beings I mean human
beings originated in Africa according to
most theories and then spread out all
over the various countenance well that
was human migration human migration has
always been a part of what we do in
response to climate all right Miranda
wants to know what do you think our
founding fathers would say about the
great divide between Democrats and
Republicans in America today I think our
founding fathers would be utterly
bewildered by both parties I think that
we have moved so far from the vision of
the founders in terms of what the state
government was supposed to do for us
what the federal government was supposed
to do what the social fabric was
supposed to do versus what the
governments
was supposed to do they look at the
Republican Party they say okay you guys
are going to spend trillions of dollars
this year you're gonna you're going to
set up a trillion dollar deficit this
year what are you even talking about and
then they look at the Democrats and they
say I would gently have no idea what
you're talking about like I don't know
what any of the terms you're using mean
I don't know what you're talking about
when you suggest getting rid not only of
key institutions but of key concepts
like biology like what are what now so
III think that they would be incredibly
confused by everything that both parties
virtually everything about parties are
doing and be kind of fun to have a time
machine Johnny Adams would be I mean can
you imagine like if you're gonna go
through historic figures on Twitter who
would be just phenomenal on Twitter oh
man
Adams would have been amazing on Twitter
Wow and trumpian on Twitter right from
from from the Oval Office that dude
would have been tweeting like everything
that came through his head because he
was incessantly writing and Alexander
Hamilton would have been vicious on
Twitter because he was vicious and
writing huh do you think he would have
rapped though no no Alicia he would not
have sorry no stage' comments no Ryan
wants to know who do you admire the most
in the political world I feel like
that's like cuz it's like somebody that
you admired two years ago you cannot
admire anymore like it happened so much
apology of the politicians and never
meet the people you admire is is the
general rule that's particularly true in
politics
they have a different job than I do it's
hard you know I have an easier job than
they do I get to sit here and tell you
about the purity of my ideas and that's
a wonderful thing and then they have to
go and try and implement those ideas and
that's that's difficult so you see
people failing to do that in a variety
of ways but people who I like and I
think are trying to do their best I mean
I've had many of them on the show dan
Crenshaw I think is trying to do his
best in the house I even though we
disagree on some things Mike Lee senator
Lee he is certainly an honest man is
trying to do his best in the Senate even
though we disagree on on some things for
sure I think that yeah I I think Ben
Sasse has the right things in his heart
although I don't know why he voted in
favor of the national emergency
declaration other than pure politics
that's exactly what I was thinking of
when I asked that question because
there's so many people that the day
before well that's been zest forever but
the
they were very disappointed right but
this is just true generally of politics
is that you either either die a hero or
you live long enough to become the
villain because sooner or later the
political stars are going to align such
that you're gonna have to compromise
your own principles the question is
whether you are honest enough to say I'm
compromising my own principles or
whether you maintain that you're
standing up for principle and you really
are not I'm really excited about this
next question from Andy who wants to
know what are the top five things
schools should be doing in America right
now that are different okay so the first
thing they should be doing is they need
to set teacher standards meaning that
Michelle reads to this in Washington DC
she tied teacher performance to teacher
pay and then the lower performing
teachers were fired so that needs to be
done immediately also we should be
paying teachers more to teach in
downtrodden communities as opposed to
upscale communities we have precisely
the reverse if you live in Los Angeles
and you're a teacher if you are senior
in the American Federation of Teachers
you'll be teaching at Beverly Hills high
if you are not senior you'll be teaching
in South Central it should be precisely
the reverse we need better teachers who
are more experienced and paid more to do
a harder job we also have to change the
curriculum and we have to get back to
teaching simple basics as opposed to
whatever politically correct garbage
people decide to shovel into the public
education system today through social
studies classes and that means how about
we read and write and learn about the
value of the American Constitution and
the American Declaration and the
ancients liked this book honestly you
know the right side of history of the
new book this book if people had read it
in like 1900 this would have been a high
school textbook maybe it might have been
a junior high textbook honestly and now
it's you know a post college textbook
because people don't know any of this
stuff so those are a few things also
more local control of Education it's not
the job of the federal government to
teach parents how to educate their
children also we have to have vouchers
we have to have parents moving their
kids from school to school the money
should follow the kid it should not
follow the teachers and finally you know
that's that's four so the fifth is that
you actually do have to break the
teachers unions the teachers unions
should not be legal public sector unions
generally should not be illegal teachers
unions unionizing against the taxpayer
is not an actual union especially when
the government is forcing people to work
for the Union in order to gain
employment we saw this with the Janet's
decision though and even in states like
California though it the unions are
still making it so difficult for
teachers to no longer
be in the Union right opt-out yeah
definitely sir I like this question
because it's actually been kind of a
question and pop culture recently
because of a favorite of ours Chris
Pratt has been hit by people for the
church that he goes to for you know
believing the Bible right in teaching
the Bible so Adrienne says that she
recently converted to Christianity and
her friend who's a homosexual says that
Christians by default hate gay people
because Christians one gave people to
sacrifice love and happiness simply
because of how they are born how would
you respond to that okay so everybody is
born obviously with different challenges
in their life I'm gonna give the
religious perspective here because
there's nothing to do a secular policy
this is just the religious perspective
so in Judaism the Orthodox believe and
the Bible suggests that homosexual
activity is a sin because this is common
to the judeo-christian value system that
does not mean that people should be
prosecuted on the second level for any
of this activity I don't think that's
right in fact I'm libertarian on
marriage because I think the government
should be completely out of all of us so
putting aside secular policy and
defending religion against this charge
it is obviously a lie the fact is that
Christians Jews people who are religious
are constantly living alongside other
people who they believe are committing
sins and we ourself believe that we are
committing sins on a fairly regular
basis this idea that we see somebody who
is committing a sin and that we hate you
because you're committing a sin
something we consider to be a sin is it
absolutely asinine if that were the case
we'd all hate ourselves we all
understand that we sin and that we are
not perfect
this is a basic religious principle
hating this in but loving the sinner you
know people try to brush that off but
that's the reality if the question is
your standard requires sacrifice of me
then yes if you were to live up to my
standard it requires sacrifice of you
that is absolutely true and that is true
of any religious standard it is so
across a wide variety of human
interactions is that sacrifice enormous
ly large when you're talking about
people who are biologically attracted to
people of the same sex of course that
sacrifice is enormously large it's an
incredible challenge to be a religious
person who's abiding by those religious
scriptures and that's why I think
religious people try to treat folks who
are gay with tremendous amounts of
sympathy or at least they should because
from a religious perspective even if you
believe people are committing a sin you
understand that people have biological
drives to do things in the religious
perspective hover and that this is an
important point in the religious
perspective a biological drive to do
a thing is not in fact immoral excuse to
do a thing and and that is a key
component of building character as a
human being now maybe you don't want to
live up to that standard maybe you feel
that the standard is ill based that's
fine that's your prerogative it's a free
country you can do what you want but if
you're at but the original question was
do Christians hate people who are gay
and the answer of course is no in the
same way that I a Jew do not hate Jews
who violate the Sabbath it's an absurd
its absurdity and it's a slander and
that's why it's so bizarre when you see
people who are tweeting out photos of
Mike Pence
oh he's next to a gay guy so the hell
what Irish Prime Minister they were so
excited Prime Minister and his husband
it's like you think Mike Pence gives a
damn like Mike do you think my Pence is
just in the other room quivering in fear
or hatred my favorite is when people on
the Left suggest well Mike Pence really
holds these views because he's a latent
homosexual he can't actually hold the
views first of all why would you
possibly I if the idea is to hit Mike
Pence and say that he's doing something
bad that's not an insult I mean from
your perspective that's not an insult in
any way at all I don't think it is an
insult period but it's it's it's so the
the whole logic of it is bizarre and
it's designed to make a character attack
on you that you know is not sure your
friend knows you don't hate gay people
your friend right you you just converted
to Christianity your friend is gay they
are your friend they should know that
you do not hate gay people if they are
bigoted enough that they believe that
your worship of Christ somehow now means
that you hate them then that means that
they're thrusting a character
description on you that is simply not
apt all right we want everyone to
remember that this is a very special
episode of our conversations because not
only daily wire subscribers get to ask
the questions if you have bought a copy
of Ben's book that he's signing today
this is a live signing for that book the
right side of history and you can get
your signed copy and I spent a question
over at premier collectibles calm slash
Ben Shapiro we're about halfway through
so we got some time we're gonna knock
out as many questions and books as
possible so go on over there to premier
collectibles calm slash Ben Shapiro to
get your copy now and submit your
questions for Ben
the next question in this next book is
from James he wants to know would you
agree that our nation if we don't stay
the course with conservative presidents
like President Trump we could possibly
end up with an America such as the one
in Orwell's 1984 or
Atlas Shrugged if not why yeah I mean of
course we can always end up in a
dystopia I mean it was Reagan who said
that freedom is always one generation
away from extinction so absolutely
I don't know that political figures
alone are going to be enough to stop
that transition I think that in the end
we do live in a republic which means
that if we go that direction it's
because the voters of America don't know
what they're doing or they've made a
poor moral decision it's why our job is
not just to vote our job is to also tell
everybody around us and teach our
children the values that we would like
to see America preserve jason says what
are your thoughts on the green New Deal
obviously it would be nice at some time
to transition to renewables what do you
would you plan what would your plan be
or what would you continue to do with
the progress that we have going towards
Pasir I mean the fact is that that there
are a couple of things that that I would
obviously do one is that we need to
actually lower taxes so that people have
more capacity to invest in the new
energy that is going to help us in the
fact in the United States has radically
reduced its carbon emissions we're the
number one emissions reducing country on
planet earth over the last several years
specifically because of fracking which
the left hate also nuclear power what
the hell if you guys are going to
proclaim that we need to get rid of
carbon-based fuels then why would you
rule out in the green new deal itself
the building of new nuclear factories
are you insane there is no reality to
this notion that you can get to net
carbon emissions of zero without
understanding that the single most
powerful method of generating energy
ever devised by man must be utilized you
know how many would you know anyway
honestly honestly how many windmills it
would take to simply compensate for the
amount of fossil fuels for the energy
grids around the United States how many
windmills the entire area of the state
of California would have to be covered
in windmills it's not a thing that's
going to happen although I'm sure some
conservatives with that solar power wind
power these do not represent a
significant percentage of the amounts of
power that is generated in the United
States what you need is fracking
replacing coal generation if you worried
about carbon emissions and you need
nuclear power replacing a lot of this
stuff if you want to worry about carbon
emissions all right AJ says what are the
most important values that should be
shared between spouses regardless of
politics so I will say that I think that
politics are a good indicator of values
so whenever I hear people say well I'm a
Republican and
getting a Democrat I think okay well
then either one of you doesn't
understand your own political viewpoint
or you have wildly differing value
systems because the Democratic and
Republican parties do represent
different value systems but
conservatives still believe that the the
messages of the past the values of the
past that you know Christian values have
something to say to us and teach us and
the left believes that we are living in
a world changing scenario where human
beings are innately malleable if we can
simply change the system under which we
live these are radically different views
of human nature and it's difficult to
see how they live together as far as as
values you have to share think about
raising a kid what do they always want
to you want to actually teach to your
children if you differ on those values
gonna be difficult for you to have a
solid marriage the truth is you can have
a marriage in which you disagree on
value so long as you don't talk politics
as long as your your goal is simply to
have fun with the person you having fun
with pretty much anybody and I can have
fun with lots of people with whom I
disagree but when the goal is raising a
child when the goal is forming a life
together then your common goal has to be
met with the same means and the same
ends and the only way to do that is to
look at those things so in the book I
talk about what my wife and I are
looking to teach to our children the
belief that you're not a victim in the
freest Society in in human history that
judeo-christian values means something
that you are you are you didn't build
the the building upon which you are
sitting right you're sitting on the top
of a building you didn't build that
building so you need to know about
everything that is underneath that these
ideas didn't come to you the world
didn't start spending when you were born
but you actually need to engage with the
ideas of the past in order to understand
what makes your life so great now that
you have a responsibility to see the
people around you as made in God's image
and that you have a responsibility on an
individual level to care for them not on
a governmental level to force you to do
something but on an individual level it
is your job to take care of your
neighbors and build social fabric and
your life has meaning and and fertilise
have meaning that means that you have to
to a certain extent believe that there
is a broader something broader in the
universe to which you are subject and
these are values I think you have to
hold in common so as easy proxies you
have to hold the religious values in
calm in in in you have to hold in common
religious values and you also have to
hold in common you know basic modes of
how you address issues I think do you
use
you use evidence it's very difficult to
deal with people if you are a reason
based person and your spouse is a deeply
emotion you're gonna have a real gap in
how you in how you communicate so I was
just totally distracted by the Barack
Obama lingo that you're using over here
there first the book is right side of
history you just said you didn't build
that right well you know I may as well
address the right side of history thing
right now so two idiots online and
they're pointing out a tweet that I
wrote when Obama was president about the
right side of history being a stupid
phrase right when you use it to say that
my view on same-sex marriage is going to
be justified by history and therefore
you are on the wrong side of history
history hasn't decided yet okay okay
history doesn't have a side if there is
a right side of history first of all to
play on the idea you know like the right
side of history as opposed to the left
side of history but if you are going to
talk about history having a right side
you have to look at the things that are
good right now and say where did they
come from you can't just say here is my
opinion on something and if you disagree
with me you're on the wrong side of
history you know I can tell that the
United States is on the right side of
history because the United States is
freaking unbelievably awesome that's how
I can tell I can't tell you however if
my tax policy is on the right side of
history because I don't have future
spectacles alrighty
Dustin wants to know in your opinion who
is the most logical choice to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsberg me Tony Barrett
shortest answer ever
there you go I mean I didn't even show
Stephens book ready and you were already
done with it should have should have
honestly should have been the the
replacement for Justice Kennedy I'm
still bewildered as to why he Brett
Kavanaugh was chosen but I mean it that
ended up being an interesting fight
though listen he once he was in it he
had to be confirmed because that was
absurd yeah disgusting but I was always
ambivalent about whether Brett Kavanaugh
would be an actual originalist or
whether he would form a new swing center
with John Roberts I opposed Roberts his
nomination I was I was very torn on
Cavanaugh I expressed my ambivalence
about it and so far I not to say I'm
always right about Supreme Court
justices but I'm kind of always right
about Supreme Court justices Stephen
says what do you believe would be the
best solution for there to be peace in
Israel I understand it's a hard question
but as I am a Jew and a dual citizen of
both America and Israel
I wonder your opinion in the matter so
there will be no peace in Israel until
the Palestinians decide that they no
longer wish to kill Jews simply for the
sake of being Jews and to liberate
Israel from the power from the river to
the sea
and it's very simple they've elected
three governments all three or terrorist
governments Palestinian Authority
Islamic Jihad Hamas are all terrorist
groups now maybe the Palestinian people
are starting to wake up to this which
would be a wonderful wonderful thing now
years ago obviously they were not awake
- this when they elected Hamas in the
Gaza Strip in 2005 after Israel
voluntarily that it vacated the place
they burned down all the Jewish green
houses then elected a terrorist group
but if you're gonna talk about
Palestinians rising up and the same
we've talked about Cubans rising up or
Venezuelans rising up that would be a
wonderful thing you think Israelis don't
want to be left alone you think Israelis
really want to be drafted at age 18 and
then do years in the military because
there are threats on every border the
thing Israelis want most is to be left
alone seriously and the Dennis Prager
uses this argument all the time and it's
exactly correct
if Israel if all the Israelis were to
put down their guns today tomorrow there
would be no more Israel if all the
Palestinians want to put down their guns
today tomorrow there would be peace all
right Shane wants to know Ben I'm an
atheist but respect and appreciate the
values in society judeo-christian values
have created and cultivates I can't
bring myself to have faith in a deity
but I think raising a child with
religious values in church attendance
would be an overall positive influence
on their life how do you recommend
reconciling these two conflicting points
I don't want to lie to my child and say
that I am religious but I also don't
want to try to explain to them why I
don't believe well they should thanks
for your dedication to the American Way
of life
I mean this is a great question and I
really do think that you should engage
your child in religious education even
if you don't believe when your kid is
old enough to have these discussions you
can have these conversations what I
would suggest that there are a lot of
people who don't believe that they are
distich who actually are theistic so if
you believe in the concept of personal
responsibility and freewill it's very
difficult to argue that on the basis of
pure atheism maybe on agnosticism maybe
you can just make the assumption but to
believe that you have the ability to
make decisions outside of the or biology
or at least to overcome your own
biological drives that you have the
ability to change and plan and do these
things requires you to believe in
something beyond the purely physical the
purely physical suggests you're just a
ball with me wandering through the
universe without any will of your own if
you believe that the universe is a place
where objective truth is possible where
you can understand the things in the
universe not just things that are useful
Darwinism suggests that are under
standing should allow us to find the
most useful solutions to problems but
not necessarily the true solution to
problems if you believe there is such a
thing as objective truth then you have
to believe there is something outside of
the materialist system that is larger
than we are and that has built the
system that there is an order to the
universe
the arguments in favor of God are not
simply God gave a bunch of words on a
mountain or God was walking around in
the Galilee one day and you know it's
it's it's an actual argument for the
logic and rigor of the universe for your
ability to act independently within that
universe that's how you can come to God
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
come to scripture the same way but I
think that coming to a realization about
the nature of God was certainly not
foreign to the Greeks I mean Aristotle
believed in the idea of the unmoved
mover all right Aaron wants to know
should common ground be something always
worthy of striving for as it is
something that is commonly seen as the
goal by many of our modern debates and
dialogues no I think that the first
thing the end goal is to define
positions and then if you can find
common ground great but in order to have
a rational discussion with somebody you
first have to define the ground upon
which you are standing one of the big
problems I see in a lot of the debates I
do and the discussions I do is failure
to define terms so people will say
things like are you in favor of
immigration reform and they're not
defining the term immigration reform I
mean I don't know you have to tell me
what immigration reform means what are
you talking about people will suggest
that it is not compassionate for me not
to believe in a certain policy and I'll
need the policy to find and also I need
you to define compassion if by
compassion you mean that I get to
leverage governments is what I want I
disagree with your definition of
compassion
if by equality you mean equality of
outcome but rather than equality of
rights then I disagree with your
terminology in order for us to have
useful conversations you first have to
define terms and then you can from there
decide where you disagree and maybe
through that clarity you find agreement
maybe you clarify each other's positions
you find that you agree more than you
thought you did
or maybe you find that you don't agree
at all and that's fine too but I always
Dennis Prager is right about this -
clarity before agreements I think is
correct but discussion before all is
also correct all right Aaron says hey
Ben I'm a huge fan are you excited for
opening day and what two teams will be
in the World Series come October so I am
a huge baseball fan as well I am excited
for opening day just by
fact that my team is not slated to be
very good this year Chicago White Sox
missed out on Manny Machado which i
think is a good thing actually but with
that said the rest of the roster is
lacking they're probably three years
away from being truly good maybe they'll
surprise me if I have to pick the team's
in advance you got to take the Yankees
in the American League they've spent a
boatload of money they I think that you
may see a slight regression to the mean
from the from the Boston Red Sox and
then in the National League I know that
the trendy pick is a little bit the
Phillies but I'm gonna I'll stick with
the Dodgers I think it'll be a Yankees
Dodgers World Series it's a throwback
World Series
I don't even pay attention to I don't
even know what that meant but I do hope
to win the March Madness bracket again
and here to do know you're not allowed
to win so Alicia won last year based on
sheer unbelievable ignorance yep she
picked an underdog team from Oklahoma to
win a couple of games no house I picked
Oklahoma boomer sooner to win it all and
they lost their first game and I'm gonna
frame the tweet from this author of the
race wins I was on the wrong side of
history and I won guys she did win but
that was because apparently was such an
upset year blah blah blah yeah that's
exactly right people just had their
brackets wrecked and then of course
there was Jared in our office who
cheated so we have a prize for the
winner and the loser so shout out to
Jared right now if you're watching Jared
up in the office let me tell you
something none of this crap where you
win the March Madness bracket for worst
bracket by picking all the 16 seeds
that's garbage you're just you're not
allowed to throw the thing man it's just
a douche move oh maybe I should do that
this year I mean I kind of want to go
out as reigning champ though I'm doing a
whole book about values and decency and
you're talking about how you can cheat
the marsh Madness brackets it's not
cheating if it's gonna teach this child
in your in your belly
Alicia Krause come on how not to work
here that book is for angel and she
wants to know what are the steps that
you took to prepare for college and did
your mentor help you well honestly I
felt like I was pretty well prepared for
college just because I was always
reading and that really is the key you
have to have good work ethic thank God
I've always had really strong work ethic
and I'm somebody who likes to get ahead
of the game so I always like to study
early my wife is precisely the opposite
she's a massive procrastinator and it
drives me up a wall
right indeed okay in these but she she
she will always wait till the last
minute so whenever there's a test date
the chess to schedule there's you know
an open period she could take near the
beginning her at the end I always just
say to her do it on the last day I know
you're gonna schedule at the beginning
and then you'll push it off all the way
till the end but you know it really is
about work ethic and and willingness to
do outside reading and that's what gets
you through college while still being a
sane human being
alright Bryan says why do you think
certain ideologies dominate particular
industries I work in tech but not for
much longer as they plan to leave partly
because of the environment that's really
sad yeah I mean I think that a lot of it
has to do with location so Silicon
Valley was founded in Silicon Valley I
mean it's in California in San Francisco
it tends to draw a lot of local people
right from the very outset it's also
true that people who are well educated
and white-collar tend toward the left
politically speaking because smart
people have a real tendency to think
that they can control other people when
I was at Harvard Law School one of the
one of the first things that happened
the very first day is Elena Kagan now
justice on the Supreme Court and in my
opinion not a very good one
she was the Dean in law school and we
were all sitting there in Memorial Hall
beautiful Hall and she walks out on the
stage and she says listen the
competition is over you're here you won
you all have jobs so here's how many
senators we have here's so many Congress
people we have here so many Supreme
Court justices we have you're gonna be
the rulers of the universe and I
remember thinking to myself why why cuz
we're smart I know a lot of smart people
and they're kind of dumb like smart
people it's great to be smart but that
doesn't mean I know anything about your
life or about how to control your family
or how you should raise your kids you
know that's your job I think there are
basic values that over time have been
improved worthy and that's what I talk
about in the book I mean there's nothing
new in the book it's a lot of old stuff
but I think that there's something to be
said for that basically a lot of the the
high IQ industries tend to go tended
toward the left because people want to
control other people's lives you see
this particularly in tech where you're
seeing Facebook and Twitter say we're
here to make the world a better place
how about you're here to provide a
platform so that we can talk with each
other and then you leave us alone how
about that how about you the Bill Gates
thing how about spare us the I'm making
the world a better place stuff with
Microsoft just give us a good product
and then you want to make the world a
better place go do it on your own
a bunch of money to charity all right
this question comes from Christopher how
can you defeat abusive delusional and
violent people with words and passivity
I mean you can't is the answer I mean a
passive position about like Antipa
versus I mean you can't but this is why
we have law enforcement so I think it's
also a mistake to give an tifo what they
want by getting in fights with them
because then they get to claim that
you're just as violent as they are and
they get to claim that they're actually
the aggressors Against Fascism in all
this kind of stuff this is why I've
always said at all of my events you know
people have said can we come to your
events and defend you against an see if
I'm like that's what the police are for
I pay lots of taxes in the state is
their job to do that all right
this question comes from Daniel oh god
do you think Michael Knowles had more
difficulties writing its book than you
writing this book I think I had more
difficulty writing more words in Michael
Moses book than he had in writing his
book how Michael Mills made hundreds of
thousands of dollars from a book that's
sold because I wrote the word thorough
on the cover is beyond me and the fact
that he still has a job here is a
testament to his friendship with Jeremy
boring I can't believe I really thought
is like a baby gift you all would get me
him fired listen you know what good idea
I'll talk to Jeremy about it well
Michael you're on notice you've got how
many months left here July fifth due
date so put in your notice severance
package I'm hopeful mines here I'm
really rooting for fourth of July baby
because that'd be awesome that would be
awesome
I mean fourth of July backstage baby
maybe I mean honestly this is my
daughter my first kid was born yep
during the State of the Union address
that Obama was giving and it was
fantastic I didn't have to cover the
State of the Union and I got a baby out
of it yeah it was great it's amazing
Zechariah says have you read any of the
Star Wars books and if so which one is
your favorite have indeed the throne
books are very very good I like the
throne books I've recommend them on the
show and that's what they should have
done when they reset star wars you
stupid idiots that you have two choices
when you reset star wars now you see
when you talk about values I'm you know
into it but when you talk about star
wars that I get passionate so here is
baseball and baseball here's the deal
that Star Wars you fools
you've absolute jackasses here is the
story about Star Wars you had two
choices and get blue it okay choice
number one you fast forward a hundred
years and then you just take up from
there and everybody is in the past they
sort of went off and had their happy
lives and now you're still in the same
universe with the same sort of machinery
and you can have you can have people
covering stuff about Han and Leia and
Luke and and bed and Kenobi in the books
and all this kind of thats fun right
that's 100 years in the future everybody
had their happy life and you didn't ruin
my childhood
number two you could just recast the
series you actually did this with Alden
Ehrenreich right you actually did this
with the solo movie which by the way I
kind of enjoyed it I liked the solo
movie I thought it was that and rogue
one were the two best of the new Star
Wars movies Nashville Star Wars Canon
movies are terrible and the reason is
because they decided to do exactly what
kylo ren's suggests they should do in
the last Star Wars movie kylo Ren says
we need to kill off all the oldies so we
can make room for the newbies and he's
the bad guy you know what Disney is
doing with Star Wars killing off all the
oldies all the people from my childhood
making them losers and then killing them
so that they can make room for a bunch
of boring boring characters that you
don't care about they turn Han Solo into
a divorce loser father who's driving
around in his old caddy and what the
hell he was the coolest guy in the
original Star Wars and then he turned
Luke into some reprobate who lives on a
planet where he milks giant space aliens
like what what was the decision-making
here what was it you if you're gonna go
for the nostalgia play you actually have
to be nostalgic you can't just you can't
just destroy the characters I grew up
with I pretend those moves aren't part
of Canada all right Grant says why has
politics become a religion for many on
the left and the right good question I
have a book for you the pieces of the
book is is why is it that we are
treating politics as religion and the
answer is because we've lost our
religion human beings have a religious
instinct we are looking for something
more important for us to be a part of we
are looking for something that motivates
us and gives us a sense of meaning you
can find that in tribalism you can find
that in anger you can find that in a
victimhood mentality you can find that
in communal ism you know the idea that
the community is matters more than the
individual or you can find that in the
values and traditions that brought us to
the greatest country in the history of
the world all right Dustin says been
that he's a longtime fan so his question
is if you could pick one thing and only
one what do you think is the biggest
problem that we as a country need to
address today I mean so on a political
level abortion is obviously the biggest
problem the continued killing of the
unborn is a great evil and as Thomas
Jefferson suggested about slavery it
when you think that God will not sleep
forever well God's justice will not
sleep forever it's a little bit
quieting as far as you know generalized
problems the problem of soul the problem
of motivation the problem of meaning and
purpose that I think is lacking in
people and and that we have to re-encode
Kate
people have to understand what an
opportunity they have been given
gratitude gratitude is the big one and
if we can install a sense of gratitude
in our kids and I think that will be
fine all right gratitude eating kids is
so important I play a game with my kids
whenever we go to the store that they
can't ask for anything oh wow how's that
go for you if they ask for something
they have to go to bed thirty minutes
early
whoa yeah you're very hardcore it wishes
a more hardcore parent than I am is the
truth like Alicia Alicia will like I
mean she takes out the belt yes call me
now I take him to church I sent him to
religious school state of California is
gonna kick me out exactly you have it
you have a smoke closet where you lock
them for data it's about religion so
brace yourself he says hi Ben if God is
perfect then why did Lucifer become
Satan and humans became corrupt thank
you so much for all you do and inspiring
me to become my school's first
editor-in-chief so if you're gonna ask
me Christian theology questions then
probably should direct those there
because in the Jewish view Satan is not
in fact a fallen angel he's not at war
with God Satan is called the accuser I
mean that's literally what's a Tom means
in Hebrew is the accuser and his job is
to be the prosecutor against human
beings and you see this in for example
the story of Job where Satan actually
shows up and has a conversation with God
and he says do you think this guy here
believes in you because you've done all
these great things for him or because he
actually believes in you that Satan's
job
Satan is like any of the other angels
yeah the in in Jewish philosophy the
angels basically have one purpose and
one purpose only in their God's
emissaries that's why the word in Hebrew
for angel malach literally means
messenger so messenger like a human
messenger and an angel it's the exact
same word in Hebrew and so for angels it
is not that Satan who's an angel is now
a bad angel or a fallen angel that's
that's not how Judaism sees it so if you
want a Christian theological view you
should ask knowles or clayvin or jeremy
or elisha
or anyone else around here actually that
wall nat Wawa mary yeah we have many
thing all the authors like it daily were
that would love to get service question
exactly i won't i won't take
you're topping off yes yeah all right we
only got about five minutes left so
let's try to roll through some more
Marvin says greetings Ben for my
daughter who oh she's a leftist please
explain the absurdity of the coalition
between feminist organizations and
people like Linda Sarsour so how is it
possible for them to coexist when
they're allegedly have these two
opposing ideologies so the truth is they
should not be able to coexist Linda
Sarsour is an advocate openly of what
she's called Sharia law she is
associated with terrorists like resmio
oda she is praised Saudi Arabia as as
liberal mean Linda Sarsour is a disaster
area of a human being and an open
anti-semite of that and for her to be
treated as a feminist icon is simply
bizarre except that the philosophy of
intersectionality suggests that none of
this actually matters intersectionality
has destroyed everything basically the
idea of intersectionality started with a
basic truth like all philosophies and
then proceeded to spin off a web of
garbage the the basic truth was that if
you look at a black woman a black woman
may be treated differently than a black
man because she is both black and a
woman right the intersection of black
and woman is different than the
intersection of black and man well that
may be true on a generic level that
should not Trump individual experiences
intersectionality however suggests that
individual experience is no longer
matter we can tell by the membership in
a group your membership and group what
experiences you have had and therefore
we can determine whether your opinion
ought to hold more or less weight in a
in any discussion and in fact people
from different groups can't listen to
each other because if we listen to each
other that suggests a common humanity
that overrides the assumptions of
intersectionality in the first place so
what that means is that
intersectionality says Linda Sarsour
can be a good feminist while also being
a rabid anti-semite and terror supporter
because after all she is a woman and a
Muslim woman which means that she has
been victimized in the United States
she's part of the victims coalition more
important that we hug the other members
of the victimhood group here then that
we actually hold fast to anything that
remotely resembles you know actual
honest feminist values all right Paige
says hi Ben I'm a woman in the military
and I'm naturally surrounded by
conservatives on a daily basis
however I've had friends have called me
a misogynist for voting for Trump how do
you suggest I open up a civil dialogue
with someone who cannot see past
identity politics and things for what so
honestly I think that you have to be
honest about this the reason that you
voted for President Trump
not because you were like on the fence
and then you heard the Access Hollywood
tape you're like yeah that's my guy that
was no.1 right legitimately no one in
the united states was like you know what
I can't say between Hillary and Trump
but now that he says that he randomly
grabs women by the genitals I'm in now
I'm in there man there was no one who
did that people voted for Trump in spite
of that stuff I'm sure you voted for
Trump in spite of that stuff you are not
embracing every aspect of Donald Trump
by voting for him all you are saying is
that you do not see how you can vote for
the person on the other side now there
are reasons that I expressed during the
2016 election for why I didn't think
that the choice was purely binary and
also what I hoped to forestall by not
voting for President Trump but I
understand why everyone did vote for
President Trump and it seems like a
fairly decent rationale saying I would
rather that his policies be put in place
with all of the drawbacks of him as a
human being than the opposite so I don't
have to defend everything from does in
order to defend his policies nor do I
have to defend my vote for his policies
on the basis of him saying terrible
things about women I've been saying for
literally years on this program and
elsewhere that president Trump's
treatment of women historically has been
garbaggio and this maintains this
continues to this day I'm not sure what
has changed or why if I then say I like
his tax cuts this makes me a misogynist
I'm confused all right this final
question comes from I hope I'm saying
this right wrong who says hi Ben what
movie or movies are you the most excited
for that are coming out in 2019 well I
mean there's the show right Game of
Thrones is coming back so I'm excited
about that that's gonna be ever watched
an episode yeah you're missing out yeah
Game of Thrones is pretty spectacular oh
they they blew it a little bit last
season but they but Game of Thrones is
really really good is there a movie that
you're excited cuz you like your theater
guy you like to go to the movie theater
room um well no one's next movie comes
out next year okay I I will say that
just like everybody else I'm looking
forward to the final installment of
infinity war because you sort of have to
say that I'm not looking forward to as
much as Alicia is because so good I'm
just pissed the date again now you know
you've got me going I know okay so
here's the deal if you cried when
spider-man or Black Panther disappear at
the end of last movie
you're an idiot no I didn't okay I'm not
accusing you I'm looking at you well I
don't know there are people I know who
are like yeah I was so sad when
spider-man's I'm like you're an idiot
he's not dead it's a billion-dollar
industry what are you yeah you're right
they killed off black
the most iconic hero they've created in
the last 15 years I'm sure they killed
him off for no reason at the end of
infinite and he's never coming back guys
maybe what it what a joke but I'm
looking forward to that I saw the the
trailer for the new Tarantino film I'm
not a huge charity no fan actually but
there's always something interesting in
the Tarantino films
I think Scorsese has a new movie that is
coming out the Irishman that it looks
kind of interesting so I'll check that
out as well those are the ones that come
to mind all right that was the last
question what don't worry that's all the
time we have for today but we thank you
to everyone who watched this very
special episode of the conversation and
asked Ben questions and it's I mean you
still got books over here so I'm just
gonna keep putting them in front of you
and you can still get your if you're
like oh no it's over I can't get a
signed copy not true guys you can still
get your signed copy over at premiere
collectibles calm slash Ben Shapiro and
be sure to tune in next month to ask
Andrew Klavan your questions on his
episode of the conversation we'll see
you next time
[Music]